[Música]
el capo del narcotráfico
mexicano rafael caro quintero fundador
del cártel de guadalajara fue trasladado
el sábado a una cárcel de máxima
seguridad era uno de los diez fugitivos
más buscados por eeuu que ya anunció que
pedirá su inmediata extradición
naciones unidas- vídeos detener el
suministro de armas haití en medio del
aumento de la violencia entre pandillas
el organismo informó que al menos 234
personas murieron o resultaron heridas
en medio de disturbios entre el 8 y el
12 de julio pasados tras dos años de
pandemia hay una paralización casi total
el turismo se recupera en américa
latina' en varios países las cifras de
visitantes llegan incluso a los niveles
previos al inicio de la crisis sanitaria
hola bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión
informativa de france 24 en español
dedicada a las principales noticias del
continente americano muchísimas gracias
por seguir acompañándonos el capo del
narcotráfico mexicano hablamos de rafael
caro quintero acusado de ser uno de los
principales proveedores de
estupefacientes a eeuu fue atrapado este
viernes en el estado de sinaloa y
transferido el sábado a la cárcel de
máxima seguridad del altiplano eeuu
anunció que buscará su inmediata
extradición
el narco de narcos en manos de las
autoridades rafael caro quintero fue
transferido este sábado a la cárcel de
máxima seguridad del altiplano de mexico
quintero ex líder del cártel de
guadalajara fue detenido el viernes
durante una operación conjunta entre la
marina y la fiscalía mexicanas sin
embargo el papel de eeuu en la captura
no está claro la directora de la dea la
administración para el control de drogas
de esa nación se felicitó de haber
colaborado con mexico para su arresto
pero el embajador mexicano salazar
aclaró más tarde que ningún personal
estadounidense participó en la operación
el arresto de este viernes es la
culminación del trabajo incansable de la
dea y sus socios mexicanos para llevar a
caro quintero ante la justicia por sus
presuntos delitos incluida la tortura y
la ejecución del agente especial de la
dea enrique kiki camarena estaremos
buscando su extradición inmediata a los
eeuu para que pueda ser juzgado por
estos crímenes en el mismo sistema de
justicia que la gente especial camarena
murió defendiendo durante la década de
los 70 15 fue uno de los principales
distribuidores de cocaína heroína y
marihuana hacia eeuu también es señalado
de haber asesinado un agente de la dea
en
1985 por lo que eeuu solicita su
extradición
quintero cumplió 28 años de una
sentencia de 40 antes de ser liberado
por un tecnicismo legal hace nueve años
era uno de los fugitivos más buscados
por la dea que ofrecía 20 millones de
dólares por información que llega con su
captura y luego de casi 3 años sin
lluvias los californianos viven una
etapa marcada por intensas olas de calor
y eventos meteorológicos extremos debido
a la crisis climática y el razonamiento
del agua es una de las medidas que el
estado estadounidense está implementando
vemos el informe
una de las sequías más fuertes de su
historia ha sido de california un
periodo seco que ya afecta al 95 por
ciento de su territorio provocado por
tres factores clave el uso descontrolado
del agua una crisis en los sistemas de
abastecimiento y el cambio climático
según el monitor de sequía de los eeuu
la mayor parte del territorio
californiano está afectado por una
sequía severa extrema y excepcional la
agricultura es uno de los sectores que
más afectados se verán una de sus
principales fuentes de agua la
cordillera de sierra nevada ha reducido
drásticamente sus niveles de nieve antes
cuando camps caía mucha nieve y la nieve
se queda en la montaña por muchos meses
hasta el verano cuando ya empieza a
bajar el agua
pero estos años se ve más lluvia que
nieve y la lluvia no se no se queda en
la montaña corre para abajo y si no la
podemos captar se va a palmar joe del
bosque un empresario agrícola
californiano siente el cambio dejará de
plantar unas 120.000 hectáreas de
almendros de california sale más del 80%
del producto para su consumo en el mundo
comerciantes como yo se quejan de la
regularización estatal para sus riegos
sin embargo las medidas de racionamiento
continuarán mientras persisten estas
condiciones
ahora los ciclos de sequía y lluvias son
más prolongados debido al cambio
climático estamos en el tercer año
consecutivo sin agua por eso es tan
grave según la unidad de monitorización
de la sequía de la universidad de
california en lo que va de 2022 ha
llovido un 30% menos de lo recomendable
bien ante las noticias naciones unidas
pidió detener el suministro de armas
haití en medio del aumento de la
violencia entre pandillas el organismo
informó que al menos doscientos tres de
cuatro personas murieron o resultaron
heridas en medio de disturbios entre el
8 y el 12 de julio pasados los 15 países
del consejo de seguridad también
aprobaron por unanimidad mantener el
mandato de su oficina en el país como
órgano para apoyar a las instituciones
haitianas de todos los miembros del
consejo de seguridad de la onu aprobaron
una resolución presentada por eeuu y
méxico el proyecto de resolución ha sido
aprobado por unanimidad el texto pide a
los estados miembros de la onu prohibir
la venta de armas pequeñas a pandillas
haitianas también incluye disposiciones
y sanciones dirigidas a los líderes de
estas bandas en mente el mandato refleja
los desafíos clave que enfrenta haití
incluida la necesidad de abordar el
tráfico ilegal de armas y los flujos
financieros ilícitos la resolución de
tiene un embargo total solicitado por
china sólo esta semana casi 90 personas
murieron en medio de la guerra entre
bandas en puerto príncipe desde el
asesinato del presidente yo en el movice
el año pasado la violencia ha ido en
aumento y las pandillas se están
aprovechando de la inestabilidad
política que vive el país
y los precios en el mercado negro se han
disparado arribando aún más la crisis en
la capital los manifestantes quemaron
neumáticos y bloquearon carreteras por
el alza de los precios del combustible
si se empeñan en subir los precios del
petróleo prendemos fuego al país también
no veía la pobreza que llega para el
aumento de la inseguridad los repetidos
secuestros y la escases de combustibles
son las principales dificultades que
enfrentamos en el país son arduas
acercándola los secuestros también
aumentan en junio se presentaron 155
casos frente a 118 reportados en mayo la
mitad de los haitianos vive por debajo
del umbral de la pobreza y las agencias
de ayuda dicen que acceder a ciertas
zonas es peligroso
y la vicepresidenta de venezuela del cje
rodríguez anunció que la sub variante de
omicron ve a punto 5 ya está circulando
en el país se hizo un llamado a los
ciudadanos a vacunarse a reforzar sus
esquemas de inmunización ante el virus
del covent 19 en la última semana
venezuela duplicó el número de nuevos
contagios diarios una tendencia al
aumento de casos que se dan a nivel
mundial con las nuevas variantes ganando
terreno a todos todos a vacunarse a
partir de los 2 años oponerse al
refuerzo estamos en un momento de
crecimiento de los casos por la
circulación de una variante de omicron
la bea punto 5 que está dando
crecimiento de los casos en todo el
mundo y en nuestro país está circulando
y después de dos años de pandemia el
turismo está recuperándose en américa
latina en varios países las cifras de
visitantes llegan incluso a los niveles
previos al inicio de la crisis sanitaria
provocada por el cob y 19 gabriel coll
quien nos cuenta más
se alistan las maletas o rumbo a américa
latina' tanto el turismo exterior como
el turismo interno están dando sólidas
señales de recuperación el pib y
turístico regional creció un 48 2% con
respecto al 2021 y el aumento del
tráfico de pasajeros aumentó
considerablemente en la región la
república dominicana ha sido señalado
como el país número uno en la
recuperación del sector en junio la isla
recibió más turistas que en toda su
historia el principal consumidor es eeuu
las reservas hechas desde el país hacia
la república dominicana méxico jamaica y
puerto rico están en aumento en
comparación con las cifras de antes de
la pandemia vemos que por ejemplo eeuu
con su con su valorización del dólar le
conviene salir a latinoamerica porque en
nuestros países hoy con esos dólares con
los que llegan pueden hacer más cosas
pero otros países de américa latina no
lo tienen tan fácil por ejemplo perú y
chile están lejos de alcanzar los
números de visitantes de 2010 en
argentina las restricciones de uso de
dólares en el exterior hicieron florecer
el turismo interno con más nacionales
bajando adentro del país pero la alta
inflación podría repercutir pse en el
consumo de las clases medias habrá un
sector del turismo interno que nosotros
si no ha cerrado números a lo mejor
puede llegar a hacer un análisis de
recortes nosotros entendemos que no va a
haber mucha caída o no va a haber algo
que es realmente impacte es una baja que
pueda ser analizada pero claramente no
no hay mejor escenario después de la
peor crisis del turismo mundial y a
pesar de los desafíos actuales américa
latina está saliendo adelante es todo
por el momento sigan en france 24
[Música]